bonjour à tous parce que je crois que
j'ai reçu un ordre comme quoi il faut
commencer alors cette plainère est
consacrée à démocratie éthique et
Nouvelle République vousz peut-être
remarqué il y a pas de point
d'interrogation après mais peut-être
qu'on pourra se poser la question si il
y a besoin ou non d'un d'un point
d'interrogation alors je suis très
heureux de inuire cette cette séance
donc mon nom est Michel verpau je suis
professeur de droit public à Paris et je
suis un habitué des universités de
rentrée pour des raisons qui sont pas
que professionnels on va
dire donc je suis très bien entouré
alors s'il vous plaît pas de remarque il
n'y a que des hommes sur l'estrade vous
l'avez remarqué c'est ainsi c'est le
hasard c'est le plus grand des hasards
n'allz pas chercher plus loin
voilà donc j'ai désamorcé la brombe euh
alors je suis très bien je suis très
bien entouré je vous le disais je vais
vous présenter en 2 secondes chacun des
personnes chacune des personnes qui est
autour de moi dans l'ordre de mon petit
papier pardon donc tout d'abord j'alla
dire à l'extrême droite pour moi mais à
l'extrême gauche pour vous Nordine
Nabili qui est directeur de Bondi blog
du bondi blog pardon et directeur de
l'antenne de l'École supérieure de
journal
de lî à Bondi c'est bien ça à côté de
moi donc michaell fe seul qui est
professeur de philosophie et à l'École
polytechnique et responsable de la chair
de philosophie de Polytechnique voilà
c'est lui qui est le plus pressé et donc
vous devinerez que c'est à lui qu'on
donnera la parole en premier pour des
raisons ferroviaires puisque les avions
marchant assez peu il a préféré prendre
le train juste à côté de moi et
bien h euh excuse-moi
euh pourtant je le connais Bastien
François je ne connais pluss pour ça que
je retou son nom Bastien François qui
est professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université Panthéon Sorbonne et puis
juste à côté et bien Luc blondot qui est
également professeur de sciences
politiques et dans la même université
n'y voyez pas non plus une sorte de
d'impérialisme d'une université euh vous
en déduirez là aussi ce que vous voulez
alors quelques mots simplement sur les
les les mots qui nous sont proposés
démocratie République et quelques mot
d'introduction très rapide je vous
rassure euh y y a-t-il un lien entre
République et démocratie je laisse de
côté le troisème mot parce que je pense
que mes collègues en parleront euh y
a-t-il un lien entre démocratie et
République euh en France ça paraît comme
une évidence ça paraît comme une
évidence et les deux sont associés comme
si euh j'allais dire la République était
forcément démocratique et la démocratie
était forcément républicaine et ce lien
interpelle un tout petit peu notamment
quand on va à l'étranger ou quand on
reçoit des étrangers qui nous disent
mais finalement il y a pas de lien
absolument nécessaire mais rappelons
simplement par exemple que la
Constitution interdit de réviser la
forme républicaine du gouvernement et
qu'est-ce que l'on entend en fait par
forme républicaine et bien ça peut être
tout autant l'absence de monarchie que
des principes républicains il serait
donc interdit de réviser des principes
républicains si vous vous souvenez pour
les plus anciens d'entre vous du
bicentenaire de la Révolution française
en
1989 et bien vous vous rappelez
peut-être qu'on a beaucoup associé
révolution et République alors même que
en 1789 c'était pas du tout la
République mais on a associé les deux et
la Déclaration des Droits de l'Homme a
présentée comme un un monument du de la
République alors que ce n'est pas
véritablement le cas et donc en France
la République est associée à des
principes républicains des principes qui
sont sont considérés comme
spécifiquement républicains et ils sont
sans doute spécifiquement républicains
parce qu'ils sont en réalité
spécifiquement français me semble-t-il
qu'est-ce qu'on range dans ces principes
souvent parce que effectivement il y a
pas une liste préétablie donc c'est
l'idée que l'on s'en fait c'est
l'indivisibilité de la République c'est
le principe de laïcité mais on précise
souvent laïcité à la française pour
distinguer cette conception de la
laïcité une autre conception par exemple
américaine c'est le principe d'égalité
devant le service public par exemple que
l'on cite souvent comme étant et bien un
principe spécifiquement républicain ce
qui nous Cuse quelques petits problèmes
vis-à-vis de nos de nos partenaires
notamment en Europe et qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'être républicain en France en
2014 c'est devenu en fait un
qualificatif politique aussi sont des
républicains ou seraient des
républicains les tenant d'un certain
nombre de principes plutôt
centralisateur plutôt étatiste plutôt
souverainiste rappelez-vous aussi dans
certaines campagnes les républicains des
deux rives c'estàdire ceux qui étaient
un peu républicains de droite et des
républicains de gauche mais qui se
réunissaient se retrouvaient autour des
l'idées de République et à ces
républicains ben on nousose souvent ce
qu'on appelle des démocrates pas
forcément au sens du Mouvement Démocrate
d'aujourd'hui mais malgré tout ça s'en
rapproche un peu c'està-dire plutôt des
décentralisateurs plutôt des libéraux
plutôt des europhiles et ces clivages
bien sûr sont un peu schématiques mais
ils existent malgré tout un peu il sont
pas dénués d'une certaine réalité et ils
traversent souvent les parties
traditionnel et on les retrouve
notamment au moment des élections
européennes où on va opposer souvent l'
les uns et les autres j'ai assez parlé
et pour des tas de raisons pour
lesquelles sur lesquelles je ne reviens
pas je passe la parole donc à M fe
merci merci merci beaucoup pour cette
invitation euh je vous dois deux excuses
effectivement le fait de devoir partir
dans très peu de temps de n'avoir donc
que peu de temps pour m'exprimer et la
deuxième chose qui fait que je m'excuse
par avance c'est que le propos que je
vais tenir eu égard à la question de la
démocratie ne sera pas nécessairement
mais je ne ferai peut-être pas preuve
d'originalité empreint d'une d'un
optimisme délirant quant à la situation
présente car il me semble qu'en France
sinon même en Europe comp tenu de la
situation politique dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons il n'est pas loin d'être
minu moins le quart par rapport aux
enjeux qui traversent de manière parfois
violente les débats politiques actuels à
l'École polytechnique j'enseigne un
cours je fais un cours en ce moment qui
s'intitule peut-on aimer la démocratie
et je dois dire dire que il y a un
certain il faut faire preuve d'une
certaine obstination pour traiter
positivement de tel sujets et ne
résister à la tentation de se mettre à
la peinture sur soi plutôt que à la
réflexion sur les principes
démocratiques et leur vitalité alors
évidemment je vais pas faire un
diagnostic général il est connu de la
crise de la démocratie française sinon
européenne le résultat des élections
européennes ou pour la première fois
depuis qu'il existe des élections libres
dans ce pays l'extrême droite quels que
soient les tentatives qu'elle fait
qu'elle est aidé à faire parfois par les
médias pour se rebaptiser arrive en tête
du scrutin j'insisterai plutôt sur le
fait que il y a aussi une crise ou que
les discours sur la crise sont eux-mêmes
entrés en crise si je puis dire
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a c'est ce qui me
frappe en tous les cas une incroyable
abstraction du discours politique
contemporain à la fois par
le retour le Light motif des éléments de
langage auquel plus personne ne croit
peut-être pas même ceux qui les
profèrent et puis à une crise du
discours aussi dans l'apparition
d'entités relativement abstraite ou même
totalement abstraite puisqu'on a
récemment déclaré sa flamme à
l'entreprise alors je ne sais pas si ici
quelqu'un parmi vous a déjà rencontré
l'entreprise bon moi je connais des
entreprises on parle a si beaucoup on
justifie la politique actuelle quoi
qu'on en pense sur le fond par un seul
terme l'emploi mais plus on parle de
l'emploi autre terme c'est peut-être
cela suscitera-t-il un débat mais qui me
semble extrêmement abstrait plus on
parle d'emploi moins on parle de travail
c'est-à-dire de la forme concrète que
prennent pour les individus leur
insertion dans la
société enfin autre type d'abstraction
dans lequel le discours politique baigne
l'identité la civilisation comme s'il y
avait du côté d'un côté des abstractions
économiques de l'autre des abstractions
politiques généralement d'ailleurs
relativement régressive il me semble que
cette question du langage est au cœur ou
du discours politique pour quantité de
raisons est au cœur de de notre de nos
problèmes actuels et je reprendrai ici
la phrase célèbre mais toujours
d'actualité d'Albert Camu selon laquelle
mal nommer les choses s ajouté au
malheur du monde alors ce qui constitue
certainement la l'aspect le plus le plus
frappant pour
moi ce qui constitue l'aspect le plus
frppant c'est que peut-être somm
sommes-nous en train de
vivre peut-être sommes-nous en train de
vivre sous nos yeux ou de voir sous nos
yeux la fin de ce que j'appellerai la
parenthèse heureuse de la démocratie
occidentale parenthèse qui s'est ouverte
me semble-t-il en 1945 dont on a pu
penser qu'en 1989 à la chute du mur de
Berlin elle trouvait une nouvelle une
nouvelle dynamique à savoir cette ce
moment historique tout à fait singulier
dans lequel la démocratie apparaissait
contrairement à ce qu'on avait toujours
dit contre elle comme un régime stable
puissant puisque ce sont les démocraties
qui ont gagné la guerre ou qui se sont
imposé ensuite contre le bloc communiste
et où en même temps la démocratie était
associée à une certaine forme de
prospérité et évidemment parler de
parenthèses peut avoir quelque chose
d'assez inquiétant à savoir qu'après
tout il n'y a rien de naturel et c'est
peut-être ce que nous sommes en train de
d'expérimenter hélas il n'y a rien de
naturel dans le goût pour la démocratie
qu'il n'y a pas quelque chose comme des
réflexes démocratiques et qu'en
particulier si l'on veut être un peu
plus précis les noces d'or si je puis
dire entre le capitalisme ou le marché
et la démocratie le fait qu'on ait pu
penser pendant longtemps que ces deux
formes disons du vivre ensemble comme on
dit aujourd'hui sont caturells et bien
nous sommes en train de nous rendre
compte qu'il n'en est rien
et que peut-être l'avenir est-il à des
formes institutionnelles que l'on
qualifierait plutôt de capitalisme
autoritaire je pense à la Chine je pense
à la Russie je pense même à la Hongrie
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas de de lien
évident entre l'équivalence monétaire et
l'amour pour
l'égalité donc ce à quoi le défi auquel
peut-être nous sommes collectivement
confrontés c'est précis prisément celui
d'une forme de ou d'une tentation en
tous les cas de divorce entre le goût
pour la liberté pour l'égalité
politiquement d'un côté et la mise en
œuvre de toute une série de procédures
économiques qui favorisent certes le
goût d'entreprendre contre lequel je
n'ai rien mais auquel je ne crois pas
que l'on puisse réduire en aucune
manière la liberté
alors je suis contraint d'aller d'aller
vite il me semble que quand on réfléchit
sur cette question de la démocratie de
la crise encore une fois terme qu'on
finit par ne plus par l'employer en tout
cas pour ma part qu'avec des pincettes
quant il devient équivoque quand on
parle de démocratie on a tort de partir
exclusivement des questions de type
institutionnel même si c'est sur
celle-là que je concluraai des auteurs
aussi différents que Marx ou toville au
19e siècle ont bien insisté sur le fait
que la démocratie avant d'être un enjeu
de ou un système pardon institutionnel
c'est une de société c'est une manière
ça n'est pas un modèle mais c'est une
série d'expériences et que s'il y a
aujourd'hui une panne démocratique
pardon de cette métaphore c'est aussi
parce que les expériences
démocratiques s sous diverses formes
associatives mais pas seulement je
dirais directement politique sont entré
en crise il y a il n'est pas naturel à
l'homme je dirais de promouvoir
l'égalité et la liberté cela ne peut se
produire que dans des contextes
historiques et je dirais même dans une
forme de
quotidienneté qui ne sont pas donné de
manière immédiate mais qui doivent être
institués favorisés par l'engagement des
citoyens et par la parole des hommes
publics ou tous ceux qui comme moi en
cet instant ont la chance de pouvoir
s'exprimer publiquement alors je je pour
dire les choses peut-être de la manière
la plus simple un dépend pour expliquer
pourquoi cet amour pour la légalité
n'est pas communément admis je citerai
un un un philosophe contemporain qui
s'est battu lui depuis son camp qui
était celui de la gauche y compris de la
Gauche communiste donc ou tout cas
trotskiste donc défiante à l'égard de la
démocratie mais qui s'est battu pour
montrer qu'il y avait dans la démocratie
une forme de vie une forme de
collaboration une forme d'expérience et
pas simplement une institution c'est
Claude Lefort et un jour Claude Lefort
qui est disparu qui qui a disparu il y a
quelques années me disait je me suis
battu toute ma vie pour promouvoir la
démocratie mais il ne faut pas pour
autant me demander d'aller au camping et
d'aimer le camping qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'il voulait dire par là il
voulait dire je crois que la démocratie
pose un problème qui est celui de
l'équivalence sinon de l'égalité des
forme de vie que ce qui est le plus
difficile à admettre dans la démocratie
c'est précisément qu'il n'y a pas une
forme de vie une forme de vie
individuelle ou une forme de vie
collective qui l'emporte nécessairement
en valeur sur les autres et il n'est
guère facile d'accepter pour chacun
d'entre nous cette équivalence qui ne
veut pas dire que tout se vaut pour
autant mais qu'il n'y a aucun savoir
aucun point de vue aucun principe qui
nous permett de hiérarchiser par avance
les formes de vie et on a bien vu encore
y compris récemment au moment des débats
si le terme s'impose mais je crois qu'il
ne s'impose pas au moment des des joute
plutôt autour du mariage pour tous ou
contre le mariage pour tous que cette
idée d'une égalité d'unégalité dans la
dignité des formes de vie était un
combat qui n'était pas gagné qui était
très loin d'être gagn alors je vais
devoir déjà conclure pour ce qui me
concerne et je voudrais le faire sur une
note non pas plus positive parce que je
n'ai pas la les moyens ni intellectuels
ni intuitif de dire vers quoi nous
allons mais conclure sur le fait qu'il
me semble que puisque la démocratie est
est sans cesse comme forme de société
elle est sans cesse menacée d'être
captée soit par le marché soit par
l'État qui sont les deux figures qui
politique l'une économique l'autre tent
de retraduire de limiter
fondamentalement ce discours ou ces
pratiques égalitaires et bien il me
semble que la solution une solution
possible peut-être la plus urgente
serait de trouver des moyens de
repolitiser les enjeux de notre vie de
notre vie collective puisque pour des
raisons que je ne peux pas ici analyser
il semble qu'il y ait un consensus on
peut le regretter d'ailleurs sur le fait
que du point de vue de l'économie et
bien dans les parties dominants du moins
la la la la la la politique de l'offre
comme on dit aujourd'hui c'est imposée
alors il reste l'autre variante ou
l'autre levier du discours politique
c'estàdire la pratique politique
c'est-à-dire les institutions et je
crois qu'il est question aussi dans
l'intitulé de cette de ce débat de la de
la Nouvelle République donc il serait
par hypothèse la 6e euh il me semble que
la la l'une des possibilités que qui
s'ouvrirait peut-être au pouvoir
aujourd'hui je dirais si François
Hollande avait l'étof d'un Kisten de
quelqu'un qui donc en Grèce ancienne a
refondé les euh les institutions et
fondé par la même la démocratie il
lancerait un grand débat sur ces
questions politiques fondamental que
sont les les question institutionnelle
dont on a trop tendance à penser
qu'elles sont très éloignées de
l'expérience des individus peut-être les
citoyens le pensent-ils parce que
l'effort pédagogique n'a pas été fait me
semble-t-il pour montrer que les
questions institutionnelles sont des
questions véritablement concrète et
concrètees au plus haut point d'alors
qu'on les réduit pas simplement
évidemment à la question de l'élection
ou du mode de
scrutin la l'idée ou l'initiative d'une
d'une nouvelle république du droit
fondation des institutions devrait
passer me semble-t-il non pas simplement
par des débats d'experts mais par la
Constitution sur une voie ou sur une
forme sous une forme qui reste à définir
d'une constituante c'est-à-dire d'une
assemblée dans laquelle qui n'a pas pour
but d'exercer le pouvoir et encore moins
de prendre le pouvoir mais c'est en quoi
cela associerait un maximum de citoyens
tout simplement de réfléchir à ce que le
pouvoir veut dire de réfléchir à ce que
faire de la politique ne er
politiquement les choses transformer
politiquement les choses signifie
autrement dit savoir ce qui relève du
politique ce qui n'en relève pas à quel
limite place-on l'intervention
collective sur l'économie quel est le
statut que l'on confère à la religion au
croyances privées quelle est la nature
de la question de la laïcité il me
semble que puisque j'étais parti de là
et que c'est par là aussi que je
terminerai dans une époque où c'est le
langage politique qui est en crise dans
une dans une époque ou dans une période
où le discours politique tente à
l'abstraction euh la plus grande et bien
il est peut-être temps de redonner aux
citoyens le soin de redéfinir les termes
c'est-à-dire de se redonner les moyens
au fond euh par leur propre expérience
c'est-à-dire par l'expérience de la
délibération du dialogue de la
discussion et du conflit euh de euh
redéfinir les termes de euh la vie euh
collective donc une nouvelle république
oui cela me paraît effectivement euh
tout à fait fait indispensable puisque
la 5e est en crise et que cette crise
est accélérée depuis l'absurde à mon
avis absurde introduction du quinquena
mais non pas simplement du point de vue
de la répartition du pouvoir mais
d'associer le maximum de citoyens à la
réflexion sur le pouvoir lui-même sur ce
qu'ils entendent exprimer bref à
reprendre cette belle formule de Michel
de certo je crois qui qualifiait la
démocratie par la prise de parole
d'abord et la prise de parole cela veut
dire redéfinir des termes qui nous
semble-t-il me semble-t-il aujourd'hui
ont cessé dans le débat public officiel
je dirais de décrire un réel qui soit un
réel que l'on puisse partager autrement
que par les angoisses ou par les colères
voilà je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup votre présentation
suscite beaucoup d'enthousiasme elle
suscite chez moi beaucoup de questions
mais avec votre permission et votre
accord une question pour Michel F une
question simplement pour des raisons de
temps si quelqu'un a une question qui
appellera une réponse
bre alors madame il y a un micro pardon
ça va venir n'oubliez pas de vous
présenter voilà nous avons unêt
sportif qui est en tenu
merci il me semble que la question de de
la liaison entre la démocratie et la
République c'est une question clé en ce
moment sur ce qui se passe en France
c'est que c'est pas la même chose la
démocratie c'est plus un mode de
fonctionnement sur un consensus de la
population sur des décisions à prendre
pour gérer le
pays et il y a le principe de l'égalité
des voix et de l'autre côté la
République c'est plus un projet de
société des valeurs qu'on veut défendre
et il faut rappeler ce triptique de
liberté égalité fraternité avec cette
équilibre où il y a à la fois de la
liberté et liberté créatrice liberté
d'échange liberté sociétale la
fraternité qui est la solidarité et puis
l'égalité et ce triptique là c'est un
véritable projet de société sur lequel
il faut un consensus et et pour pouvoir
adhérer à ce projet de société on a
besoin de la démocratie donc les deux se
répondent et donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut vraiment
dépasser ces clivages gauche droite le
problème du Front national c'est qu'il
faut remobiliser les gens sur ce
triptique sur la République et c'est que
comme ça en se mobilisant sur les les
vraies valeurs républicaines sur un
projet de société y compris
économique voilà que on on pourra y
arriver
euh alors qu'il y ait une différence
entre la République et la démocratie ça
me paraît effectivement tout à fait
exact je suis pas sûr de la la placer
exactement là où où vous la placez la
République je dirais en tout cas la
République française puisque vous vous
avez fait écho à la sa devise c'est une
version de la démocratie et c'est une
version de la démocratie euh qui comme
forme de société pas simplement comme
système électif c'est une version qui
effectivement repose sur un certain
nombre de principes je préfère le mot
principe au mot valeur sur un certain
nombre de principes mais précisément je
dirais c'est une manière de stabiliser
la démocratie la démocratie a quelque
chose encore une fois comme forme
d'échange de soci de société comme comme
comme système où les arguments se se
répondent les uns aux autres sans que il
y ait un savoir qui puisse mettre terme
à la discussion la démocratie a quelque
chose
d'illimité nous ne cessons de discuter
et on le voyait j'étais hier soir à
votre plainère j' ai participé on voyait
bien que vous n'aviez pas enfin certains
d'entre vous envie que çaela s'arrête
bon et c'est très bien comme ça la
République c'est une manière d'apporter
une limite à cette ilillimitation
démocratique qui a ses propres
perversions son propre ses propres
risques que cela ne s'arrête jamais que
la dé libération l'emporte sur la
décision la République c'est aussi une
discussion ou c'est plutôt une une forme
pardon institutionnelle qui permet
d'apporter un certain nombre de limites
à la démocratie par exemple vous l'avez
rappelé même si le peuple le veut en
droit majoritairement et bien on ne
pourra pas remettre en cause la forme
républicaine de l'État la Constitution
c'est précisément ce qui vient limiter
par avance un certain nombre de dérive
possibl de la démocratie je crois que
toute la difficulté c'est de trouver un
équilibre entre cette illimitation démoc
que et cette limitation républicaine ou
disons étatique qui n'ille pas qui
n'aille pas je dirais trop trop
fortement dans un sens et le risque
aujourd'hui me semble-t-il c'est plutôt
celui d'une limitation trop forte par
l'État et peut aussi par le marché par
des formes disons d'organisation
institutionnelle de ce qu'il y a tout de
même de positif dans l' liimitation
démocratique c'est-à-dire la mise en
scène des conflits en tant que personne
ne peut y mettre un terme de manière
autoritaire
est-ce
que pour essayer de mettre pour pour la
salle et nous tous qui sommes là une
minute les idées un peu en place pour
nous en tout cas la République nous on
est des militants engagés sur le terrain
des élus assez souvent la République
c'est au sens commun du terme une forme
politique c'est l'organisation
les institutions la
Constitution et les gens disent on est
en République puis la République c'est
une deuxième chose Marianne n'avait pas
tort de le dire c'est un en France le
mot républicain c'est un projet
politique qui en effet se singularise ou
se caractérise par le triptique que nous
savons liberté égalité fraternité et
c'est pourquoi lorsqueun certain nombre
de gens par exemple extrémiste disent
mais quoi on n'est pas républicain on
est en république les gens votent pour
nous on peut leur opposer le fait que
leur vision du monde leur projet sur le
monde ne correspond pas aux valeurs
républicaines qui sont
énoncé au fronton de tous les
établissements publics ça c'est la
première chose démocratie je pense que
c'est utile de définir ce que ça veut
dire ça n'est pas seulement le vote ça
n'est pas seulement le débat perpétuel
pour nous qui avons choisi l'adjectif
démocrate ou qui aimons l'adjectif
démocratique dans chacun des intitulés
nombreux des formations politiques qui
ont incarné ce courant politique moi
j'aime beaucoup la définition de Marc
sier qui dit la démocratie est
l'organisation sociale qui vise à porter
à son plus haut la conscience et la
responsabilité de chacun des citoyens la
consci
et la responsabilité et on voit qu'il y
a là un projet
politique qui dépasse et va plus loin
que le projet républicain puisqu'il vise
non seulement à réaliser ou à incarner
ce triptique mais à faire que chacun de
ceux qui est membre de la société en
question de la communauté en question en
soit un membre de premier rang dans la
responsabilité et il me semble que si on
articule les deux alors on comprend
pourquoi la Constitution a écrit la
République est démocratique laïque et
sociale et et et cette ce cette liaison
intime qui a été faite dans le texte
constitutionnel pour nous justifie
l'équilibre français le le le projet
français l'idéal français que nous
essayons d'incarner et de réaliser ici
pardon d'avoir ajouté cette
précision je merci je naai pas
grandchose à ajouter à ce que vient de
dire François Baayou je vais devoir y
aller je vous remercie de votre de votre
de votre
attention j'ajouterai juste simplement
en écho à ce que vient de dire François
baayrou que démocratie ou République ce
ne sont pas contrairement à ce que
parfois une certaine idée de l'état de
droit droit laisse penser ce ne sont pas
des formes neutres de vie sociale que
même s'il y a une imp il doit il devrait
y avoir une impartialité de l'État cela
ne veut pas dire ou cela n'implique pas
me semble-t-il que la démocratie ou la
République là c'est les deux IR enfin
vont dans le même sens ce ne soit pas un
ensemble aussi de choix qui appelle vous
vous en avez parlé une responsabilité
donc une implication des individus et
que ce n'est pas simplement un système
électif dans le au fond règnerait des
opinions qui seraient par principe
équivalentes voilà merci et bon débat à
vous
tous
merci et bon bon retour les les quelques
minutes qui viennent de se dérouler
montrent la la richesse des questions
qui ont été qui ont été posé je serais
assez d'accord avec la définition qu'on
a donné madame tout à l'heure sur la
c'est Marianne entre entre la démocratie
et la République mais je vais pas
mimisser de dans dans le débat sur le
capitalisme autoritaire il a pris
l'exemple de la Chine de la Russie on a
quand même des exemples en France dans
l'histoire qui sont ceux de des empires
qui sont aussi des qui étaient aussi des
régimes à la fois
capitalistes libéraux sur le plan
économique mais aussi très autoritaire
donc c'est aussi une phase de de de de
notre histoire qu' faut pas oublier
euh tout à l'heure il a été question de
Nouvelle République et on a glissé tout
de suite vers la 6e république mais un
des débats mais je sens que mes voisins
vont intervenir là-dessus c'est est-ce
que c'est une 6e république ou une 5e
République refondé c'est quand même une
question qui est pas totalement anodine
et je ne suis pas sûr de partager tout à
fait ce qui va être dit par la suite
mais justement c'est l'objet bien on
verra on verra on verra puis un dernier
mot il a dit qu'il il ne connaissez pas
le mot emploi enfin ne pour avoir un
fils au chômage depuis 1 an je peux vous
dire que
euh le fait le mot emploi c'est pas
c'est pas un mot entre guillemets vite
c'est pas une abstraction on veut bien
qu'on ne rend compte pas l'entreprise
mais l'emploi euh on rend compre quand
on en a pas et c'est le fait notamment
d'être utilisé de servir à quelque chose
et de ne pas avoir d'emploi c'est une
véritable réalité c'est pas seulement
une abstraction pardonnez-moi c'est
quelques mots personnels voilà alors je
donne la parole je préféreris ne pas
avoir dit ça d'ailleurs vous en doutez
euh je donne la parole à louï que j'ai
appelé Luc tout à l'heure par donne-moi
euh pour donc euh une dizaine de minutes
à peu près merci euh merci euh euh vous
m'entendez le le le casting est plutôt
bien fait même si il y a une nette
domination de vieux mblanc euh à la
tribune euh on a on a un philosophe qui
a qui a pris la parole en premier moi je
suis plus plutôt un sociologue et je
pense que le le regard va va va glisser
aussi vers plutôt les institutions et le
droit et moi je vais poursuivre ce que
Michel fossel a entamé c'est-à-dire
l'autopsie de notre démocratie je vais
vous proposer un tableau clinique une
sorte d'état critique des lieux de la
démocratie contemporaine dans les
démocraties libérales représentatives
occidental hein ce sera le le l'objet de
mon exposé je vais posé trois questions
la première va vous paraître peut-être
iconoclaste un peu provocquante c'est
sommes-nous encore en démocratie voire
même avons-nous jamais été en démocratie
hein donc je vais rappeler un certain
nombre de d'évidences dans un second
temps je vais moi aussi éviter le
vocabulaire de la crise qui est un
vocabulaire tellement aujourd'hui érodé
qui n'a plus de sens mais je vais
réfléchir et faire l'inventaire de ce
qui menace aujourd'hui la démocratie
hein par en haut par en bas partout tout
qui sont les adversaires de la
démocratie aujourd'hui et dans un
troisième temps je vais donner quelques
raisons d'espérer qu'est-ce qui peut les
sauver hein là où les les menaces sont
sont croissantes les raisons d'espérer
aussi peuvent l'être et développer trois
stratégies de
rénovation de
réanimation de nos démocraties premier
élément sommes-nous encore en
démocratie voire même avons-nous jamais
était en démocratie premier point point
d'histoire les pères fondateurs de nos
institutions c'est-à-dire de ce que nous
appelons aujourd'hui la démocratie
représentative haïsait la démocratie à
la fin du 18e siècle aux États-Unis en
France les les les constituant ont voulu
trouver un régime alternatif à la fois à
la monarchie absolue et à la démocratie
la démocratie était jugé comme un régime
dangereux archaïque euh impossible à
pratiquer dans dans les grandes nations
et surtout irresponsable c'est-à-dire
comment confier le le la décision à des
citoyen à la fois incompétent et
toujours facteur de désordre sies la dit
très bien en
1789 les
représentants parlent et volulent pour
la nation point bas hein c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait il y a substitution des
représentants au peuple à la nation il y
a une souveraineté populaire de principe
mais dans la pratique le peuple n'a pas
à gouverner lui-même il a à désigner des
représentants donc quand on parle de
démocratie représentative on a affaire à
une sorte d'oxyore c'est-à-dire d'une
contradiction dans les termes la
démocratie ne saurait pas être
représentative puisque la représentation
n'organise pas le gouvernement du peuple
par lui-même ça c'est un point
d'histoire deuxème élément sommes-nous
encore en démocratie là je vais partir
d'une autre définition que celle
proposée par François berou une
définition de spécialiste de sciences
politiques je vais l'emprunter à un de
mes collègues américains qui s'appelle
Robert Dall qui est un qui n'est pas un
gauchiste hein c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire il est il a décédé récemment
c'est un des vraiment des des grands
politistes de du 20e siècle et il
propose une définition que je trouve
assez robuste en CIN points avec un
point principal premier point il y a
démocratie lorsque chaque citoyen a une
chance égale d'influencer la décision on
pourrait même se limiter à ça une chance
égale d'influencer la décision là nous
sommes en démocratie
deuxème point il y a démocratie lorsque
tous les suffrages se valent hein c'est
le principe un homme une voix troisème
condition il y a démocratie lorsqu'il y
a une compréhension éclairée des enjeux
par chaque citoyen qui lui permettent de
se prononcer de voter en accord avec ses
convictions et avec ses intérêts donc la
qualité du débat public de l'offre on
pourrait traduire ça en offre médiatique
elle est tout à fait importante 4è
élément il y a démocratie lorsqu'il y a
un certain contrôle par le peuple de
l'agenda des
gouvernants 5è point il y a démocratie
lorsque tous les intérêts sont pris en
compte à par égal dans le processus de
décision principe d'inclusion tous les
intérêts pris en compte à PARG dans le
processus de décision chacun a la même
chance de voir ses intérêts défendus
dans le processus de décision voilà CIN
points qui me paraissent tout à fait
important et si on les prend un par un
tous à l'exception d'un seul aujourd'hui
ne correspondent en aucun cas à l'état
de nos démocratie il serait absolument
irréaliste de dire que chacun a une
chance égale d'influencer le processus
de décision il serait irréaliste de dire
que chacun a les moyens d'avoir une
compréhension éclairée des en jeu qui
lui permettent de voter de se prononcer
en accord avec ses convictions et ses
intérêts il serait irréaliste de dire
qu'il y a un contrôle par le peuple de
l'agenda des gouvernants et il serait
parfaitement irréaliste de dire que tous
les intérêts sont pris en compte à part
égal dans le processus de décision nous
avons des démocraties qui sont
inégalitaires qui privilégient certains
points de vue dans les médias qui
privilégient certains intérêts dans le
processus de décision tout ça est
aujourd'hui évidemment constatable il y
a un seul élément qui nous rapproche de
la démocratie c'est le principe un homme
une voix mais la question se pose est-ce
que la démocratie peut se réduire à
l'élection c'est à mon avis l'un des
enjeux vraiment fondamentaux de cette
réflexion sur la démocratie donc
avons-nous jamais été en démocratie
c'est douteux il sommesnous aujourd'hui
c'est douteux également et certains
n'hésitent pas à dire que nous avons
changé de formes politiques nous sommes
dans ce qu'on appelle dans ce que le le
sociologue anglais Coling Crouch appelle
la
postdémocratie comme sous la République
romaine tardive et au début du
Bas-Empire romain nous avons les
apparences de la démocratie nous avons
un sénat une assemblée un peuple nous
avons des élections mais nous ne sommes
plus en démocratie très clairement après
cette entrée en matière iconoclaste je
vais poser une seconde question
qu'est-ce qui fait que les menaces qui
pèsent sur la démocratie aujourd'hui euh
euh devrait euh nous angoisser et
devrait nous inquiéter sur la survie
même de cette cette de de cet embryon de
démocratie qui est la démocratie
représentative je ne parle pas de crise
parce que effectivement ce vocabulaire
de la crise est très problématique hein
supposerait que l'on revienne à un état
idéal de la démocratie je vais parler de
processus de désintégration de processus
d'implosion de processus qui est à la
fois interne aux institutions mais qui
est lié aussi à tout un ensemble de
facteurs sociaux économiques culturels
très différents premier élément nous
avons aujourd'hui un processus
d'évidement du pouvoir politique
d'abaissement du pouvoir politique par
rapport au pouvoir économique la sphère
économique c'estes logiques ces volontés
ces acteurs aujourd'hui ont pris le pas
sur le pouvoir politique dans un
processus de servitude volontaire
d'asservissement mais qui est vraiment
très dangereux pour les libertés donc
cette extension à l'indéfini indéfinie
de la sphère économique au aujourd'hui
est délétaire mortifèire pour le pouvoir
politique deuxè 2uxè élément il y
a une incapacité c'est-à-dire ça n'est
pas une crise seulement de légitimité
c'est une crise d'impuissance il y a une
incapacité des pouvoir politique à
régler les problèmes urgents de ce temps
les questions économiques mais aussi les
questions environnementales je reprends
l'expression de de Pierre Rosenvallon
très juste les institutions
représentatives sont Myop elles ne voi
jamais plus loin que la prochaine
élection et elles sont incapables de
prendre les mesures qu'il faudrait
aujourd'hui pour régler cette crise qui
qui va très vraisemblablement emporter
avec elle la démocratie qui est la crise
environnementale hein et qui que nous
vivrons
hein nous hein ça n'est pas pour nos
enfants hein bon mais comment
représenter les intérêts du long terme
dans nos démocraties c'est une question
troisième élément il y a un niveau de
défiance atteint par les acteurs
politiques par les partis politiques
hein et effectivement je n'ai pas le
temps de revenir sur ce que sont les
partis politiques et ce qu'ils pourrai
faire aujourd'hui mais qui a atteint des
niveaux vertigineux défiance à l'égard
des acteurs politiques mais défiance
aussi à l'égard de toute forme
d'autorité toute forme d'expertise on le
voit dans tous les débats publics et
j'en observe beaucoup les experts sont
démonétisés plus personne ne croit à
leur impartialité tout le monde pense
qu'ils sont sous influence et ça donne
sur Internet la la floraison de théorie
du complot sur le mode tout le monde
nous personne ne nous dit la vérité nous
ne pouvons plus croire personne et ça
c'est très dangereux pour finalement un
pouvoir politique qui s'est appuyer
aussi sur une légitimité d'expertise
nous avons le sentiment d'un dénis de
représentation d'une partie
significative et croissante de la
population nous ne sommes plus
représentés comme le disaient les les
les les indignier espagnol vous ne nous
représentez pas ce dénis de
représentation évidemment fait le lit de
l'extrême droite qui elle présente
encore une promesse de représentation
des intérêts mais il est absolument
dramatique les adversaires de la
démocratie ils sont là évidemment les
populismes les
extrémismes effectivement qui ne sont
rien d'autre qu'un processus de
réenchantement du politique comme si le
pouvoir politique pouvait encore
s'imposer comme si la politique était
autre chose que de la gestion euh comme
si on pouvait encore désigner des
adversaires faire communauté
politiquement il y a une promesse de
politique une promesse même de
démocratie d'un certain point de vue
mais de démocratie tellement déviée
qu'elle est problématique de démocratie
directe qui est derrière cette tentation
populiste et ça c'est pour le la la base
mais au sommet est-ce que nos élites
croient encore en la démocratie est-ce
que nos
élites ont encore confiance dans la
démocratie est-ce que N n'ont pas
tendance que ce soit les élites
technocratiques les élites européennes
les élites économiques est-ce qu'elles
n'ont pas tendance à avoir peur de plus
en plus de la démocratie souvenez-nous
du du du moment de la crise financière
lorsqu'il s'est agit de faire un
référendum en Grèce que n'-t-on entendu
sur le risque de ce recours à la
démocratie hein il y a une tentation
autoritaire mais aussi une tentation
technocratique gérons les sociétés comme
les
marchés faisons en sorte de leur
appliquer les solutions qui sont les
nôtres et qui sont bonnes pour le peuple
mais que le peuple est incapable de
découvrir et puis vous avez la montée à
bas bruit aujourd'hui d'une critique des
institutions de la représentation qui
est tout à fait intéressante me
semble-t-il si on s'intéresse un peu à
Internet au milieu des activistes qui
réfléchissent sur ces questions de
démocratie il y a aujourd'hui une
critique qui s'exprime qui s'est exprimé
dans le mouvement occupa qui s'est
exprimé chez les indignés qui s'est
exprimé en Italie pour le meilleur et
pour le pire avec le mouvement de bppé
griillot mais quand même un quart de
l'électorat c'est pas rien cette
critique elle elle elle elle remet en
cause fondamentalement les institutions
de la représentation de l'élection elle
préconise le tirage au sort elle
préconise une assemblée constituante
citoyenne tirée au sort elle elle
préconise une forme radicale de réforme
de la démocratie j'ai participer à un
documentaire qui s'appelle j'ai pas voté
hein dans lequel on a affaire à une
critique de l'élection ce documentaire a
été mis sur youtube il n'a pas été
acheté par les télévisions il a été mis
sur Youtube en quelques jours 100000 vu
et un nombre de partages tout à fait
exceptionnel ce qui pour ce type de
thématique témoigne de l'émergence
finalement de proposition à la fois
critique et alternative alors maintenant
comment s'en sortir pour ne pas sortir
ici trop désespéré hein après cette
cette éégie funèbre d'un idéal
finalement que nous n'avons jamais
vraiment
connu trois trois éléments me
semble-t-il qui correspondent trois
directions qui correspondent à ce qu'est
la démocratie au fond c'est-à-dire la
démocratie c'est trois processus trois
sphères trois trois dimensions qui
entrent en tension les unes avec les
autres et on ne peut pas réduire la
démocratie à l'une de ces dimensions la
première de ces dimensions c'est sa
dimension institutionnelle il est hors
de question de jeter aujourd'hui le bébé
avec le du bain on ne peut pas du jour
au lendemain substituer la démocratie
directe à la démocratie représentative
il me semble que la réforme
institutionnelle aujourd'hui mais
d'autres en parleront mieux que moi est
impérative il faut déprofessionnaliser
l'activité politique qui est devenue
hyper professionnalisé très clairement
il
faut malgré avec toute les palinodis et
cetera mettre fin clairement au cumul
des mandats dans l'espace mais aussi
dans le
très
clairement il faut alors là ce sont les
mesures les plus consensuelles mais il y
a des mesures qui sont que que moi je
défends qui sont un peu plus un peu plus
que que contestable et contesté dans
dans la culture politique française il
faut un recours beaucoup plus fréquent
au référendum et une
vraie liberté d'initiative populaire
honnêtement très clairement même si je
ne suis pas content toujours de ce que
produisent les initiatives en Suisse je
préférerais être un citoyen Suisse qu'un
citoyen français hein je pourrais à ce
moment-là m'exprimer sur une certain
nombre de questions dernière mesure que
les élus mais même les citoyens
détestent en France le vote obligatoire
alors voilà là en général ça fait un
flop mais le vote obligatoire comme
moyen
de compensation des inégalités sociales
de l'élection aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
que les catégories populaires ne votent
plus et si elle ne vote plus elle ne
compte plus rendre le vote obligatoire à
mon avis changerait vraiment les choses
donc démocratie institutionnelle d'aut
en parlons mieux que moi cette
démocratie institutionnelle elle doit
faire le ménage en son sein pour ne rien
dire des mesures sur la transparence
nous sommes très loin du compte
aujourd'hui il y a un enjeu de
moralisation de l'activité politique
deuxième dimension la démocratie
citoyenne ce que Rosenvallon appelle la
contred-démocratie Rosenvallon a dit
dans son dans son très bon livre sur la
contredémocratie il n'y a pas de
démocratie sans tension entre la
démocratie institutionnelle et la
démocratie citoyenne pourquoi parce que
quand les citoyens se désintéressent de
la politique quand les citoyens
regardent ailleurs quand ils sont des
consommateurs lorsqu'ils se replient sur
la sphère privée c'est ce que disait à
Athènes Périclès c'est ce que disait
tokville à ce moment-là ils ont toute
chance de laisser échapper le le le
cours de leur destin et de voir le
pouvoir transférer à des acteurs qui ne
les prendront plus en compte aujourd'hui
c'est un peu la situation depuis
vingtaine d'années une trentaine
d'années tout est fait pour dissuader
les citoyens de s'intéresser à la vie
politique tout est fait pour les
transformer en consommateur à la fois en
les gouvernant par le désir et par la
peur hein la peur de perdre ce qu'ils
ont et le désir de consommer et on ne
peut pas être citoyen lorsque finalement
en soi c'est un peu ce que disait Michel
fossel le consommateur a vampirisé le
citoyen celui qui et on peut par exemple
on peut analyser le référendum Ecossais
de cette manière c'està-dire que
finalement à à en Écosse mais bon sous
bénéfice d'inventaire j'ai pas travaillé
mais c'est le sont les consommateurs
ceux qui ont eu peur de perdre leur
pouvoir d'achat qui qui l'ont emporté
sur ceux qui avaient une vraie
aspiration à la liberté mais on pourra
on pourra on pourrait en rediscuter
discutable et puis deuxième élément qui
me paraît tout à fait tout à fait
important il y a chez les citoyens des
sources d'innovation des solutions
qui ne sont pas visibles des politiques
je crois beaucoup à l'idée d'expertise
profane d'expertise d'usage je crois
beaucoup à la démocratie du faire les
citoyens sont capables de contribuer au
processus de décision infiniment plus
que ne le croient en général les
techniciens et les politiques qui
pensent avoir la solution infuse il y a
chez les citoyens des solutions qui
renvoient aux formes politiques
elle-même
le mouvement des Indignés tout ce dont
deux de mes collègues qui dans un
bouquin très très bon qui vient juste de
sortir appelle tous les mouvements qui
qui défendent le principe démocratie he
je vous renvoie au livre de Sandra
logier et Albert Ogien le principe
démocratie principe démocratie à la
découverte ces mouvements inventent de
la politique ils promeuent des
alternatives politiques et il pourrait
me semble-t-il
réanimer les ition démocratique et pour
ne pas être trop long je vais insister
sur un trisème sur une troisème sphère
de de à la fois d'institution et de de
formme politique qui est ce que
j'appelle la démocratie délibérative et
c'est là-dessus que je travaille en
général la plupart du temps la
démocratie délibérative c'est quoi c'est
cette sphère qui est à à l'interface
entre la démocratie citoyenne et la
démocratie institutionnel c'est ce qu'on
appelle vulgairement en France mais un
mot qui a été complètement démonétisé
démocratie participative c'est-à-dire ce
sont des lieux où le processus de
représentation politique prend
véritablement forme c'est-à-dire ce
processus par lequel les représentants
mettent à l'épreuve leurs solution
auprès des représentés c'est ce c'est ce
lieu où les représentants viennent
rendre des comptes en dehors de
l'élection dans l'intervalle entre les
élections au représentés c'est ce lieu
où la légitimité respective des citoyens
et des acteurs politiques est mise en
tension et c'est ce lieu que l'on peut
faire exister au travers de tout un
ensemble de démarche de dispositifs
juris de citoyens conférence de citoyens
débat
public concertation mais tout cela
obéissant à des règles d'impartialité et
d'inclusion très forte tous ces
mécanismes là à mon avis sont
nécessaires pour avoir une démocratie
authentique et pour avoir un véritable
processus de représentation politique on
pourra y revenir mais il y a des
expériences qui marchent ça n'est pas
parce qu'en France on méprise toutes ces
toutes ces formes politiques c'est pas
parce qu'en France on les
instrumentalise c'est pas parce qu'en
France le mot démocratie délibérative
gêne à l'oreille parce que nous disons
que la délibération c'est le fait des
élus oui les élus continuent à décider
mais la délibération c'est la la
formation de la décision qui produit la
légitimité de
celle-ci conclusion tout ça sera-t-il
suffisant ça n'est pas sûr tout comme
Michel Fessel je suis très modérément
optimiste sur ces points je ne suis pas
d'un optimisme ba sur la possibilité de
voir les citoyens se réveiller et se
réveiller dans le bon sens sans confier
leur destin à des à des à des à des des
gouvernants autoritaires je ne suis pas
convaincu que l'on puisse finalement
avant avant le la la fin mettre en place
tout ça il il faudrait aussi hein me
semble-t-il que ils prennent en main
clairement leur leur leur destin et que
ils se rappellent comme l'a dit Michel
fossel et là-dessus je suis tout à fait
d'accord que la démocratie c'est une
forme de
vie autant que des institutions
c'est-à-dire c'est une manière d'être
ensemble de construire ensemble
l'intérêt général de construire ensemble
l'avenir sans ce sentiment de défiance
aujourd'hui y compris dans le conflit
qui est qui qui est généralisé voilà
merci merci de m'avoir écouté euh ce
car merci pour ces propos tout à fait
tout à fait intéressant et stimulant euh
avant de passer la parole directement à
à Bastien François parce que je crois
qu'il y a il y a un lien direct entre
les deux euh simplement on pourrait se
poser la question de savoir si nous
n'avons jamais été en démocratie contenu
quand vous dites est-ce que nous sommes
encore la question serait est-ce que
nous l'avons jamais été compte tenu des
définitions que vous avez donné je crois
qu'on peut répondre en réalité jamais et
puis deuxième remarque qui va peut-être
servir de transition très très facile
avec Bastien François c'est il a été
question à plusieurs reprises ce matin
d'e d'une
constituante comme si c'était un élément
déclencheur pour lancer un phénomène les
constituantes on en a vu récemment dans
les pays arabes après ce qu'on a appelé
les printemps arabes et on a vu les
difficultés que ça peut entraîner et
puis les constituantes en France l qu'il
y en a eu c'était souvent après des
chocs politiques les constituantes sont
rarement arrivé dans une situation entre
guillemets de calme absolu c'est soit la
guerre soit une révolution soit autre
chose voilà donc Bastien François la
parole merci beaucoup bonjour à toutes
et et à tous Je je j'avis pas prévu de
parler de constituante mais non mais non
mais c'est très très bien je je vais en
dire un mot parce qu'effectivement ce ce
mot commence à occuper à prendre du
poids dans dans les débats actuels bon
je voulais commencer en en remerciant le
modem de de son invitation alors c'est
pas simplement parce que je remercie le
modem de son invitation en soi oui merci
mais
euh je pense que c'est dans la période
actuel et sur ces questionsl il est très
important que nous nous parlions
moi-même je suis universitaire mais
aussi un militant et un élu écologiste
euh je suis très heureux d'être là pour
vous parler et j'aimerais que d'ailleurs
que vous veniez aussi chez nous enfin et
cetera je je crois que la période la
période est euh est suffisamment grave
euh pour qu'on discute euh alors moi
j'ai été invité j'ai bien compris euh
euh pour un des éléments du triptique
qui qui donne son titre à à cette
plinière c'est le le l'élément Nouvelle
République bon
et savoir si c'est une nouvelle
république point d'interrogation ou pas
ce que disait Michel verpau est-ce que
c'est une 5e rénovée une 6e république
j'y reviendrai alors je je je
partage presque
totalement l'analyse que vient de de de
de de faire devant vous lï blondot
euh avec peut-être une petite différence
et que moi je suis personnellement plus
optimiste peut-être parce que je suis un
militant politique je suis dans un parti
je vois des militants politiques et je
sais qu'il y a une force là il y a a il
y a de la croyance et bon et que les
choses je les vois de façon un peu moins
froide que l'universitaire qui
effectivement du point de vue
universitaire a une situation
objectivement très difficile bon j'y
crois quand même et j'y crois d'autant
plus que je crois que nous
vivons si je voulais les regarder la
période d'un point de vue optimiste une
période formidable parce que nous sommes
nous allons être obligés d'inventer un
nouveau monde et il y a pas beaucoup de
de situations comme ça où on va devoir
repenser entièrement notre société
c'est-à-dire que nous allons devoir
repenser la
production la consommation le
travail la fiscalité nous n'avons pas le
choix hein je veux dire nous vivons je
vais revenir je vais revenir plus tard
nous vivons quand même dans un monde
jusqu'à présent qui s inventé entre le
18e et le 19e siècle et là nous devons
inventer un nouveau monde 21e siècle on
ne sait pas très bien comment l'inventer
on tâonne mais il y AEL il y a quelque
chose d'extraordinairement excitant dans
dans cette dans cette dans cette
situation là de dangereux mais aussi
d'excitant
alors pour dire les chose simplement
leï a beaucoup parlé je je il m'a piqué
un certain nombre de choses bon je je je
vais je vais mais oui puis en plus lui
il a un talent exceptionnel donc moi
derrière voyez c'est bon le le je je je
vais retenir trois points qui seraient
euh euh qui seraient parmi d'autres hein
mais qui seraient trois enjeux enfin
trois problèmes trois enjeux de de ce
que pourrait être le chantier de cette
nouvelle république
euh trois points sur lesquels il
faudrait en tout cas dont je suis sur
lesquels je suis sûr qu'il faut qu'on
discute ça veut pas dire qu'il en a pas
d'autres et que ces points d'ailleurs se
déclinent pas en d'autres points et
cetera le premier point je vais
l'appeler responsabilité
les
régimes représentatifs se sont
construits sur une idée assez simple
mais très forte sur l'idée de la
confiance et cette confiance
elle se paye de quelque chose qui est la
responsabilité le problème dans notre
pays c'est que responsabilité n'existe
plus la 5e République non pas en
elle-même non pas le texte lui-même mais
la façon dont la pratique la l'a façonné
la 5e République a fait disparaître au
sommet de l'État la
responsabilité de fait nous élisons un
chef suprême qui pendant 5 ans
maintenant
euh ne va jamais quoi qu'il arrive
supporter une épreuve de confiance
d'où les tentations de de la d'où la
possibilité de la
trahison par rapport au mandat qui a été
accordé d'où l'absence de limite d'où
d'une certaine façon la distance mais
qui est presque inscrite dans les gènes
des institutions entre l'exercice du
pouvoir et la société bon et d'où en
plus c'est ça qui a commencé C date pas
d'aujourd'hui d'où cette petite maladie
qui a fait descendre petit à petit
l'irresponsabilité du sommet de l'État
jusque enfin dans dans toute la chaîne
de commandement de l'État bon voilà et
et l'enjeu l'enjeu il est de
restaurer ce principe de responsabilité
ce principe très
simple les Anglais ont un terme pour
parler de ça et qui est peut-être qui
est très difficile à traduire mais qui
qui est peut-être plus plus fin c'est
accability le fait que les gens à qui on
a accordé la confiance pour nous
gouverner doivent rendre des comptes sur
l'usage qu'ils ont fait de cette
confiance en permanence et à tout
moment alors restaurer la confiance ça
veut dire des choses extrêmement simples
pour des pour des gens comme Michel
verpau et moi des constitutionnalistes
c'est régime parlementaire parce que
c'est le régime parlementaire est fondé
sur la
confiance sur la responsabilité donc
restaurer un ça veut dire restaurer un
vrai régime parlementaire ça c'est pas
du tout révolutionnaire c'estàdire avoir
un système euh le même que dans les tous
les autres pays de l'Union européenne
sauf Malte donc c'est pas très très très
révolutionnaire mais enfin ça serait
quand même sortir de l'exception
française
mais c'est donc je vais pas entrer dans
le détail mais c'est aussi et c'est là
que c'était important ce que disait le
blondot c'est aussi conr politiquement
le temps entre les
élections c'est-à-dire effectivement et
là aujourd'hui dans la boîte à
outils
démocratique dans les expériences qui se
construisent
partout on dispose de ce qu'il faut pour
remplir le
temps positivement
entre les élections tout ce qu'on
appelle l a raison d'appeler ça plutôt
de la démocratie délibérative que de la
démocratie participative qui est un
terme un petit peu galvod
mais justement tous ces temps où le
politique va être obligé ou le
représentant est obligé de partager un
certain nombre de choses et obligé de
répondre et obligé de s'inscrire dans
des débats et obligé d'une certaine
façon de rendre des comptes mais pas
d'une façon
négative de rendre des comptes dans la
dynamique même du débat de la
construction des projets des politiques
publiques et cetera et il y a de ce
point de vue-l
beaucoup de possibilités alors qui sont
on le sait maintenant plus ou moins
efficaces plus ou moins utile et cetera
bon je renter pas dans cette question
mais j'imagine qu'il y aura des
questions qui seront posées à ce propos
donc le premier point enfin le premier
enjeu le premier le premier problème
c'est la question de la confiance c'est
la question de la responsabilité c'est
la question des mécanismes par lesquels
on peut arriver a restaurer ce principe
de confiance qui encore une fois est
indissociable d'une épreuve particulière
qui est là ce qu'on appelle en droit
constitutionnel en droit politique la
responsabilité le deuxème point qui me
semble extrêmement important que vous
connaissez bien c'est la question de la
qualité de la
représentation alors là il y a un
chantier
immédiat qui est qui est pas un petit
qui est le chantier des modes de
scrutin nous avons un mode de
scrutin qui est pas propre à la 5e
République c'était le mode de scrutin
qui existait sous la 3e république par
exemple mais qui est indissociable de ce
qui est devenu la 5e République c'est le
mode de scrutin majoritaire uninominal
majoritaire à deux tours ce mode de
scrutin a des effets extraordinairement
pervers
nous avons aujourd'hui une
représentation qui est dans un
état voilà
désespéré pas simplement sur le plan
sociologique pas simplement sur le plan
démographique mais encore que ça
compte l'Assemblée nationale ressemble
un peu à nous tro de ce
côtél et franchement il faut dire la
vérité à tout point de vue
social âge sexe
revenu on ressemble pas au français
c'est pas grave en soi mais quand quand
les représentants ressemblent aussi peu
au français
bon ça c'est un aspect l'autre aspect
c'est que la France
représentée ne ressemble pas du tout à
la France
électrice si vous prenez l'ensemble des
députés de gauche et de droite
l'ensemble à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
moins que 50 % du corps électoral mais
alors comment vous quand on dit on dit
la majorité bah la majorité ça fait 25 %
déjà bon et quand vous voulez engager
des grandes réformes de structure vous
engagez des grandes réformes de
structure avec des gens qui représentent
en
réalité
voilà plus qui sont pas du tout
représentatif socialement attendez quand
vous faites une réforme des retraites et
qu'il y a que que qu'il y a un député
y a 9 députés sur 10 qui ont plus de 60
ans excusez-moi évidemment c'est assez
cool de faire des réformes de retraite
qui vont jamais s'appliquer à
vous voilà sans compter toute une série
de toutes les
questions 3è
perversité dont on parle peut-être un
peu moins parce qu'elles sont moins
faciles à illustrer mais je pense que
ici au modem vous ilerez
sensible voilà un système qui empêche
quand même qui
oblige a des formes de
bipolarisation et qui et empêche des
formes de recomposition qui peuvent être
nécessaires à tel ou tel moment mais qui
peut croire par exemple que la droite
c'est
l'UMP qui peut croire que la gauche
c'est le PS bien sûr que ça n'existe et
ils sont
malheureux ils sont malheureux parce
qu'ils sont pas bien par ex
PS ou il y a une fracture énorme qui est
la fracture européenne énorme et qui est
quand même identitaire pour nous tous
ils sont mal mais ils ont pas le choix
ils ont pas le choix je dire pour les
frondur du PS je mets le place ce qu'on
appelle les frondurs mais Val c'est un
affreux de
droite et pourtant il est dans le même
parti et donc c'est difficile d'être en
même temps j'imagine socialiste avec un
gars de l'UMP qui est premier ministre
donc ce mode de scrutin c'est le le mode
de scrutin qui est pour nous vraiment un
EMI immédiat parce que c'est le mode de
scrutin qui nous
empêche de rediscuter entre nous oui et
puis de reconstruire des alliances parce
que on sait très
bien c'est pas monsieur Baou a la vérité
tout seul c'est pas donc on va devoir
construire oui oui mais je préfère le
dire parce que je sais voilà le le le
voilà donc vous voyez la question de la
représentation c'est pas simplement de
la voilà c'est du mode de
scrutin c'est
aussi
de de la
dynamique des systèmes politiques de la
souplesse et puis
évidemment il faut encore ajouter ce
point mais loï a déjà dit beaucoup de
choses c'est que c'est aussi aujourd'hui
je dis bien aujourd'hui parce que hier
c'était différent c'était nécessairement
différent hier je prends toujours cet
exemple en 1958 il y a 180000
étudiants aujourd'hui il y a
2500000 on est dans un pays beaucoup
plus éduqué qui a accès beaucoup plus
d'information qui qui est qui est
beaucoup plus capable on le voit chacun
d'entre nous de peser de construire de
partager de de de de de de
d'expertiser et donc la question de la
porosité hein la question de la
représentation c'est aussi la question
de la porosité entre les représentants
et et ceux qui sont représentés et
des de de la capacité à s'ouvrir
ponctuellement
ou et moi par exemple moins que les les
référendum je défendrai mais vraiment
très fortement la question de de l'iniit
itive législative citoyenne la capacité
et compris dans les collectivités
locales la capacité d'interpellation
d'inscription d'un certain nombre de
question sur sur l'agenda des élus ou
dans l'ordre du jour donc là il me
semble qu'il y a un chantier alors qui
qui est alors qui peut être réalisé très
vite parce que là l'obstacle qu'on nous
met chaque fois il faut une révision
constitutionnelle il est pas là et je
crois que on pourrait même si on était
un peu moins
euh abîmé par la logique de la 5e
République parce que c'est un poison qui
abîme tout le monde euh je crois qu'on
pourrait d'ailleurs assez vite même
construire dans l'Assemblée nationale
actuelle une majorité qui permettrait de
bousculer le pouvoir exécutif en place
sur ce si si si si mais il faudrait oui
ça ça suppose une grande intelligence
hein mais si on n pas si on fait pas le
Paris de l'intelligence en tout cas de
tout ce dont on est en train de parler
ne servirait à rien donc là il y a un
chantier extrêmement important puis il y
a un troisième chantier
dont on parle beaucoup moins mais Don
que loï a évoqué qui me semble
absolument fondamental qui est peut-être
un petit peu abstrait mais on peut pas
mettre sur le
métier une nouvelle République sans se
rendre compte que les schémas avec
lesquels nous raisonnons ont été pensés
il y a de siècles
euh ça vaut pour la question de la
démocratie elle-même
le mais ça vaut aussi et pour moi c'est
c'est un des sujets essentiels ça vaut
pour la question de la temporalité de
l'action
politique aujourd'hui nous savons bien
que les enjeux ce sont des des enjeux de
long terme voire de d'extrêmement long
terme que les questions
budgétaires mobilisent des enjeux de
long terme VO d'extrêmement long terme
et c'est pas que la dette don je sais
qu' ici depuis longtemps on a on a dit
l'importance structurante et les
dangers mais nous devons inventer une
société qui se préoccupe une société
politique qui se préoccupe des
générations futures voilà et ça c'est
extrêmement difficile parce que nous
sommes dans des systèmes qui n'ont pas
du tout été pensés pour ça parce que la
question ne se posez
pas nous savons qu'elle se pose et c'est
compliqué parce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire une assemblée par exemple une
assemblée qui représenterait des
intérêts des générations futures comment
on définirait les
représentants donc là il y a aussi un
c'est mais en même temps c'est là que
l'enjeu est extrêmement excitant c'est
là cl l'en jeu est beau c'estclen jeu
n'est plus
simplement bah on essaie d'avoir un truc
mieux qui marche mieux on change des
petits trucs dans la Constitution tout
ça non l'enjeu c'est de se dire on va
inventer un système institutionnel du
21e siècle et je crois que là il y a
quelque chose sur lesquels on pourrait
essayer de mobiliser de construire et
compris avec sans doute d'autres acteurs
que nous c'est-à-dire d'une certaine
façon voilà entre le professeur de
philosophie à Polytechnique le
professeur de droit public à parien le
professeur de sciences politique à
parien aussi bon et moi euh ça fait
beaucoup peut-être trop heureusement on
n'est pas les seuls ça fait peut-être
trop d'expert il faudrait peut-être
commencer à construire des dialogues
voilà
alors et puis je viendrai à la
Constituante puis j'aurais fini la 6e
république moi je voudrais qu'on appelle
6e
République ce chantier pas
plus je voudrais qu'on appelle parce que
sinon on va fétichiser des choses on va
pas s'en sortir je voudrais qu'on se
dise simplement quand qu fait la 6e
République c'est que la la 6e république
ça serait simplement ça serait déjà pas
mal un dialogue pour refonder les les
institutions on verra ce qu'il en
sortira on verra jusqu'où on ira et à la
rigueur moi je m'en fiche totalement du
numéro je m'en fiche de savoir si c'est
5e rénové ou 6e on s'en tape en revanche
nous avons besoin d'un drapeau qui nous
rassemble et qui qui nous permett de
nous reconnaître et ou derrière lequel
on se dise oui ben c'est des démocrates
qui se disent qui ont pris la
mesure de cet enjeu là et qui veulent
travailler avec les autres dans un
esprit d'ouverture dans un esprit de
coopération ça veut pas dire dans la
molesse he ça veut pas dire qu'il doit
pas avoir des principes derrière ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut pas être
radicaux alors simplement sur la
Constituante bon moi je dois vous dire
que je crois que Michel verpo le laisser
entendre dans la façon de s'exprimer je
je suis modérément
euh
voilà pourquoi je crois je crois que le
problème c'est qu'on raisonne souvent
avec des instruments du passé la
Constituante c'est un instrument du
passé je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
des instruments délibératifs je dis pas
qu'il faudra pas qu'il en a une à un
moment mais je dis que nous avons des
instruments délibératif qui permettent
de faire des choses beaucoup plus
sophistiqué regarde ce qui s passé en
Islande je crois que si nous voulons
mobiliser véritablement notre pays
sur la refondation du PACT
démocratique je pense que la
Constituante d'une certaine façon quelle
que soit la façon dont cette
constituante sera désigné ça serait
fermé trop tôt le débat et on verra s'il
faut une constituante mais je crois
qu'il faut surtout prendre le temps de
construire très profondément un débat et
construire très profondément des lieux
d'émergence de coproduction de
caboration de solutions il faut prendre
le temps alors vous me dirit en Islande
c'est un tout petit pays c'était assez
facile à faire sans doute mais après
tout nous les
français qui racontons partout queon est
les champions du monde alors évidemment
on en a fait tellement de constitutions
qu'on peut dire qu'on a de l'expérience
bon mais voilà nous la franceche de 1789
patati patata ben ça serait quand même
la classe qu'on soit capable de monter
un dispositif de construction du PACT
démocratique qui soit adapté au 21e
siècle voilà et donc c'est c'est c'est
c'est pour moi la Nouvelle République on
va dire ça serait d'abord commencer par
ça c'est montrer en
pratique dans les principes
d'élaboration que nous sommes
effectivement sur la voie d'un renouveau
démocratique je vous
remercie
merci à Bastien François qui complète
très bien ce qui vient d'être dit dans
ce panel de d'hommees d'un certain âge
blanc si j'ai bien compris autour de la
al justement pour sortir un peu de ce
panel mais avec quelques contraintes de
temps cette fois-ci c'est pas le train
mais la
restauration parce que nous sommes très
nombreux ce qui est une bonne chose mais
du coup ça pose quelques petites
difficultés je vous propose 4 c
auqu on essera de répondre de manière
groupée pour laisser la parole quand
même à notre dernier
intervenant bon alors si le chef a dit
j'obéis merci
beaucoup merci mon histoire familiale
retiendra que François berou président
du MoDem a défendu la prise de parole du
petit gamin Nordine d'abord moi je suis
très je suis je suis très heureux d'être
là je réponds rarement en
réalité aux invitations des partis
politiques pour une raison très simple
c'est que je suis journaliste et que un
des versants de mon travail c'est
justement d'inviter les responsables
politiques et donc
euh donc intervenir dans dans dans dans
une dans une réunion politique c'est un
peu compliqué pour moi mais j'ai accepté
parce que d'abord je connais très bien
le travail du modème et surtout parce
que François berou a fait justement
l'effort devenir il y a il y a 2 ans ou
3 ans dans une expérience que nous avons
monté il y a quelques années abondi en
scen S et donc il a fait une émission de
télévision avec avec nos jeunes et ça
répond finalement à ce qui a été dit par
les interlocuteurs précédents moi moi je
voudrais
euh je n'ai pas l'ambition de de de dire
des choses plus intelligentes ou plus
pertinentes
euh que mes mes collègues ici à ma
gauche je voudrais juste vous parler
d'une d'une d'une d'une unee partie de
la France ou en tous les cas d'une
France que moi je connais dans laquelle
je vis dans laquelle j'ai
grandi et que je ne retrouve pas ni dans
les discours politiques et encore moins
dans les médias et finalement ça
répondra d'une manière très concrète à
un certain nombre de de de positions
idéologiques politiques universitaires
qui ont été évoqué ce matin d'abord la
France est une vieille dame euh très
vieille dame
euh c'est une shibania comme on dit en
arabe et dans et et pour nous le le le
mot Shibani c'est c'est c'est un mot
affectif c'est un respect que nous
devons évidemment à des gens qui ont
beaucoup d'expérience et qui doivent en
tous les cas avoir le seul objectif que
de transmettre cette cette cette
expérience au plus jeunes parce que au
fond moi j'ai toujours été éduqué avec
cette idée que le rôle primordial et
principal d'un adulte c'est d'aider un
gamin à grandir voilà c'est c'est c'est
assez basique mais après on peut le on
peut le on peut le décliner le le
deuxème point c'est que tous les débats
depuis 20 ou 25 ans en France en fait
sont portés nourris argumentés par une
petite élite par une toute petite élite
qui ne représente de mon point de vue
pas la
société française et cette élite
finalement se nourrit en permanence des
mêmes itinéraires c'est-à-dire que en
gros vous avez aujourd'hui les gens qui
sont en train d'intégrer cette élite
politique économique médiatique c'est un
peu les mêmes que qui l'ont intégré il y
a 20 ou 25 ans ou 30 ans et ainsi de
suite et moi je pense que le véritable
problème de la société française c'est
pas tant ses institutions mais sa
reproduction sociale sa guerre
silencieuse du séparatisme social
l'envie d'être dans l'entre soi ça c'est
des questions fondamentales qui
aujourd'hui finalement nourrissent les
stratégies de la tension politiques qui
sont aujourd'hui présentes dans tous les
partis politiques peut-être à
l'exception du modemme mais en tous les
cas on voit bien on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on ne gouverne que par la
peur la peur de la crise la peur de
l'étranger la peur du la religion la
peur des jeunes et ainsi de suite
l'autre aspect c'est que moi j'ai la
chance de vivre dans un monde très jeune
c'està-dire que on a parlé des vieux
mâles blanc
euh mais il bourgeois il se trouve que
on a on a évoqué les quartiers
populaires tout à l'heure les quartiers
populaires c'est les endroits les plus
jeunes de France c'està- direire que la
jeunesse de France est dans les
quartiers populaires dans ces quartiers
populaires vous avez 45 % de gamins qui
ont entre 16 et et 25 ans qui sont au
chômage c'est le double de la même
catégorie sur tout le territoire
français donc ça c'est le problème
numéro 1 et moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous quand vous dites
l'emploi l'emploi c'est peut-être plus
important que la liberté dans les
quartiers populaires parce qu'il faut
d'abord avoir un emploi faut d'abord
être utile faut d'abord avoir quelque
chose à faire en se levant le matin et
si on narrive pas à mettre cet espoir là
dans toute cette génération tous les
discours ne serviront à rien et donc moi
mon travail depuis une quinzaine
d'années autour du bondi blog donc en sc
saint c'est justement de remettre de
l'espoir là-dedans et de l'espoir il en
vient pas des partis politiques hélas
parce que les partis politiques en tous
les cas la représentation politique les
gens qui aspirent cette fameuse
confiance qui nous est demandé
régulièrement à échéance régulière
finalement est souvent très
et je pense que le si la France est
aujourd'hui benne dans une espèce de de
bassin anxiogène elle le doit d'abord à
sa propre classe politique ça c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est très
important alors l'autre aspect
évidemment évidemment que il faut
nourrir la classe politique il faut
nourrir la classe médiatique les
économistes etins ENF le monde de
l'économie ainsi de suite le problème
c'est qu'en France vous n'avez quasiment
pas le droit à une deuxè ou à une 3è
chance sauf quand vous êtes un
politique le problème en France aussi
c'est que les gens qui matin midi et
soir nous parle de l'assistana ont été
longuement assistés pour réussir leurs
études par exemple je pense notamment
aux aarqu il faut savoir qu'un Narc
aujourd'hui en France coûte 180000 €
pour ces 2 ans
de formation un jeune qui a le même âge
dans une faculté par exemple en sa
sainten coûte 15000
€ 15000 € 170000 € voyez on peut changer
les choses moi je pense qu'on peut
changer les choses d'une manière un peu
stratégique et un peu volontaire et le
vrai problème en réalité c'est que nous
confions nous citoyens trop de pouvoir à
nos politiques qui eux sont minés par le
poison du cours terme et du culte du
chef et ça et ça si on n'arrive pas
parce que croire croire que la solution
politique
d'une d'un pays comme la France ne peut
venir que d'un homme avec son catalogue
dans une globalisation et on parlait
tout à l'heure de de l'image de la
France croyez-moi quand vous quand vous
voyagez la France elle est belle dans la
tête des gens qui ont fait des études en
entre 1950 et
1975 parce que à cette époque là la
France avait une parole la France compé
dans le concert des nations aujourd'hui
je ne suis plus tellement sûr de cette
place là donc il y a une espèce de rêve
aussi entretenu voilà et le dernier
point puisqu'on me dit qu'il faut que je
conclu hélas parce que j'avais encore
quelques mais bon ce n'est pas grave
c'est pas grave voilà
continue
et et et le le le le dernier point le
dernier point et puis après je répondrai
bien évidemment aux questions mais le
c'est que lorsque lorsque vous vous vous
vous essayez de monter des choses
justement pour essayer de de de
permettre de libérer la parole
finalement de casser les normes euh de
de de permettre à des gamins d'écrire et
donc d'interpeller donc finalement
d'utiliser le stylo le clavier euh et
non pas donc le le le le le cocktail
molotophe ou la voiture qui brûle vous
avez un système qui vous regarde en
pensant que tout ça ce n'est que de la
récréation or la réalité c'est que le
monde a changé et la France n'est pas
consciente du tout ne serait-ce que ne
serait-ce que par exemple sur la place
médiatique aujourd'hui l'opinion se
construit dans les médias vous le
vouliez ou non c'est comme ça donc voilà
voilà aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la place
médiatique est plus forte que la place
physique la place physique telle qu'elle
a été évoquée par les sociologues
c'est-à-dire les partis politiques les
institut tion l'église les marchés les
bistr tous ces endroits où se fabriquait
finalement l'opinion pendant les 30
glorieuses parce qu'on ne se posait pas
la question à l'époque du marché du
travail moi j'ai grandi dans une cité
dans les années 70 où le plus cancre
d'entre nous trouv un job le plus cancre
d'entre nous d'ailleurs les plus cancre
d'entre mes amis d'enfance gagnent plus
d'argent que moi aujourd'hui en tant que
journaliste et en tant que directeur
d'une école réputée de journalisme pour
une raison très simple c'est que le
marché du travail
absorber quelque chose on était dans ces
fameuses Trente Glorieuses donc donc la
question de la crise française elle
n'est pas seulement économique elle est
aussi morale elle est aussi identitaire
c'était finalement une très bonne
question cette fameuse question de
l'identité française elle a été mal
posée il se trouve que je pense que la
France devrait s'interroger sur son
identité avec des sociologues avec des
ethnologues avec des historiens et non
pas sous l'gite des préfectures de
police et c'est
ça
donc se poser des questions sur
soi pour construire la cohésion sociale
pour finalement lancer ce pays dans les
50 ou 100 ans à venir c'est c'est des
questions légitimes comme un gamin
aujourd'hui qui a 12 13 ans a besoin de
savoir et connaître l'histoire de ses
propres parents de ses propres
grands-parents qu'est-ce qui fait que
lui aujourd'hui avec sa peau noire se
retrouve comme français à partentière ça
c'est des questions qui sont légitimes
mais c'est des questions qui sont trop
importantes trop cruciales pour les
laisser uniquement aux partis politiques
c'est ça la la difficulté et le dernier
point puisqu'il faut quand même que je
respecte les consignes c'est que le
court terme ne pourra jamais nous
dessiner ce que nous serons dans les
dans le siècle avenir le court terme
c'est un truc de commercial c'est c'est
c'est voilà la politique c'est autre
chose et et et l'ultime réaction c'est
qu'il faudrait peut-être même se mettre
dans la condition psychologique de la
sortie de la guerre en 1940 c'estd que
aujourd'hui le système français en tout
cas toutes les avancées sociales
françaises ont été construites à la
sortie de la de la deuxème guerre
mondiale parce qu'on s'était dit on ne
veut plus ça or aujourd'hui on n pas
besoin d'attendre une guerre fut-elle
sociale il faut absolument absolument
prendre conscience que d'une part le
public la population et ça a été dit la
population est intelligente croyez-moi
s'il y a 70 % de gens qui ne vote pas en
scène Saint-Denis c'est pas parce que
ils ne comprennent pas c'est peut-être
même parce qu'ils
comprennent donc il faudrait presque
interpréter cette cette abstention
finalement ce cette défiance comme une
preuve de maturité politique et pourquoi
pas et notamment les jeunes et arrête de
dénigrer ce qu'on appelle le web
l'Internet l'Internet n'a pas
d'idéologie l'internet c'est de la
tuyauterie
et làdedans on met des produits
évidemment les premiers à avoir intégré
les premiers à avoir investi cet outil
c'est les gens qui était mise à l'écart
du système médiatique et forcément c'est
souvent ce qu'on retrouve avec tous les
ismes qui qui puissent exister dans la
langue française c'est-à-dire les
intégristes les sexistes les antisémites
et ainsi de suite mais tout ça ils vont
être un moment de nouveau minoritaire il
retrouveront leur petite place don voilà
donc si vous voulez moi je suis vous
dire ça c'estàd qu'il y a une situation
anxiogène une situation difficile mais
quand on a à mon âge et quand on a
l'histoire familiale qui est la mienne
on n pas le droit de baisser les bras on
n pas le droit de baisser les bras mais
on a le droit d'être lucide et
aujourd'hui hélas et on le voit encore
avec ce qui va se passer ce weekend
demain soir et ainsi de suite on n pas
encore pris conscience de la réalité de
la situation même si la France a
toujours été un grand pays il y a aucune
chance qu'elle implose mais par contre
la France n'a plus la place telle
qu'elle l'imagine ou telle qu'elle
euh euh ou tel qu'elle cela qu'elle
qu'elle la raconte finalement et donc ça
c'est un vrai enjeu qui aujourd'hui est
capable de parler à la France en face
au-delà des titres que l'on a dans les
émissions de télévision des paroles et
des acte euh on dit la vérité t non
c'est qui veut parler à la société
française et qui veut faire l'effort
nécessaire parce queon veut bien de la
mixité sociale mais loin de chez soi
c'est ça qui est aussi compliqué voilà
merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
alors je suis très ennuyé parce qu'en
fait je devais participer à cette table
ronde et pas simplement la diriger mais
vous avez compris que j'ai remplacé donc
j'avais deux trois choses à dire mais je
vais pas vous les dire et du coup non
non et du coup ben je reviendrai une
prochaine université de rentrée il y a
un mot simplement un mot qui a qui a été
un peu oublié dans c'est le mot
d'éthique je vous rappelle que notre
plainère a été autour de TR et il y a un
mot d'éthique et je crois qu'il y aurait
des choses tout à fait intéressantes
mais comme je suis un grand
démocrate et bien je vais donner la
parole aux personnes dans la salle parce
qu'on donne pas la parole à la salle
parce que la salle ne parle pas mais aux
personnes qui sont dans la salle
simplement si je comprends bien les
instructions on me dit trois questions
alors je laisse la personne au micro se
débrouiller avec pour sélectionner les
trois questions voilà merci beaucoup
excusez-moi hein c'est pas oui merci de
me donner la parole en fait je la je
l'espérais depuis le début bon bien sûr
les les exposés ont est extrêmement
brillant et je vais tenter moi en tant
que citoyen simple d'illustrer par une
situation concrète le premier
intervenant qui n'est plus là hélas a
évoqué par exemple dans les difficultés
dans les fractures de représentation et
bien le les
manifestations contre le mariage pour
tous pour illustrer le fait qu'une
partie de la population avait du mal à
intégrer une certaine équivalence des
des
formes d'association de couple et
cetera en cela il a pas été très méchant
puisque les manifestations pour le
mariage contre le mariage pour tous ont
été taxés beaucoup plus fréquemment
d'être rempli de d'intégristes
catholiques d'une part d'extrémistes
d'extrême droite et puis bien entendu
d'homophobe avec un un mot beaucoup plus
cru et je crois que c'est important de
revenir sur ce point parce que si vous
voulez quand plus d'un million de de
Français passent un dimanche entier
prennent le quart viennent de loin
passent 15 à 18h pour aller
s'exprimer et bien ils sont dans
l'espoir que on va pouvoir les entendre
et pas seulement disqualifier ce qu'ils
ont ce qu'ils tentent de dire comme
c'est des propos de rejet d'homophobie
d'extrémisme
d'intégrisme je peux vous le dire pour y
avoir été c'est un vrai problème la
plupart de ceux qui y étaient ne se sont
pas retrouvés dans ce que disait la
presse les d'une part le chiffrage de
300000 que nous a assuré Monsieur Vax il
a confisqué les photos hein il y avait
plus d'un million de personnes mais la
plus grande question qui était posé par
les gens qui étaient sur place et qui
n'étaient pas des bouffes
c'était bien entendu les gens ont le
droit de vivre comme ils l'entendent la
question est est-ce que la société se
doit de de fournir des enfants à ceux
qui ont une sexualité différente et donc
de priver les
enfants de priver les enfants d'avoir et
un père et une mère et la question elle
était là et personne n'a accepté que le
devoir existe c'est un dénis de
démocratie auquel la classe politique et
la presse a participé on nous a refusé
de pouvoir discuter de ça est-ce que un
enfant a droit à un père et une mère et
bien ceci a été occulté au profit
ce sont des extrémistes des homophobes
des intégristes et du Front National et
bien c'est une insulte à la démocratie
merci pour vos propos qui n'appelle pas
vraiment de réponse ici d'autres
questions il y avait des mains là
pardon Marianne bon je pense qu'il
faudrait une limite d'âge pour être
député sénateur et puis peut-être faire
passer des tests psychologique avant
d'entrer à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat sans doute un peu partout ça une
oui non une question très courte
euh vous avez parlé monsieur blondot en
fait c'est plus pour vous vous avez
parlé de d'une des mesures que vous
avvez cité c'était le vote obligatoire
et quand j'entends Nordine monsieur
Nordine Naili je me rends compte à quel
point ce serait difficile si on tenait
pas compte par exemple du vote blanc
n'est-ce pas donc c'est ça la condition
d'une part et puis quand on entend que
90 % des je
ne vote pas ça nous amène à nous dire à
quel point la c'est une énorme menace
sur la démocratie et on n parle pas
assez non il va de soi pour moi que le
vote obligatoire n'est concevable
qu'avec reconnaissance du vote blanc et
quand on aura 70 % de de votes blanc on
s'apercevra de la faible
représentativité politiques et ce sera
une incitation très très forte à changer
donc c'est c'est ça dans dans mon esprit
c'est évident estce que ça sera très
différent de constater 70 % d'abstention
oui oui parce que ça voudra dire qu'on a
affaire à des gens politisés qui croient
encore à la démocratie parce que la
manière dont on parle des
abstentionnistes en général on les
disqualifie alors même que la la
l'abstention pas toujours est une une
peut être une position politique en
démocratie il y a toujours 15/5e de la
population qui se désintéresse
totalement de l'univers politique c'est
une sorte de constante au 20e siècle et
au 21e siècle mais au-delà de ces 20 %
on peut pas croire que les 30 % qui sont
pas allés voter ne sont pas politisé ni
intéressé par les est-ce que je peux
répondre s'il vous plaît d'abord c'est
pas 90 c'est 60 mais vous savez le vote
c'est une culture en réalité
c'est-à-dire que moi par exemple je n'ai
jamais vu mes parents voteryz je n'ai
jamais vu mes parents voter or
aujourd'hui il se passe pas une élection
sans que mes enfants m'accompagnent
voyez donc c'est oui c'est toute la
différence c'està dire que tous les amis
avec qui j'ai grandi c'était souvent
d'ailleurs des communistes par exemple
aller le dimanche c'était la fête
familiale en fait le vote donc c'est
pour ça que le le le le la le débat sur
le vote des étrangers dépasse largement
la question la nation de la République
c'est c'est une question philosophique
c'estàdire que vous vous intéressez les
les gamins à la lecture c'est pas 17 ou
à 18 ans c'est des voilà c'est une
culture le vote c'est la même chose
c'est comme le débat et la confrontation
S c'est Lenon qui disait avant de
vouloir faire la révolution faites
d'abord la révolution dans votre propre
famille c'estàd qu'en réalité la
politique c'est d'abord dans la famille
et et une des dimensions je pense qui
est ignorée c'est ça c'est que au fond
pourquoi les gens ne vont pas voter mais
parce que les gens ne se sentent pas
dans le système et donc après il faut se
poser la question pourquoi ils ne le
sont pas et pas pour dire mais parce
qu'ils sont musulmans non c'est pas ça
c'est c'est parce que il y a il y a des
ruptures en réalité et c'est ça qui est
intéressant et donc c'est pour ça que le
débat sur le le vote des étrangers comme
le le débat sur le vote obligatoire doit
donner ces dimensions là à la réflexion
publique parce que c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas un d'abord c'est un c'est
un droit c'est bien de mettre au même
niveau tous les citoyens de ce pays mais
au-delà de ça parce que c'est quelque
chose qui répond peut-être à une partie
de la crise dans laquelle nous
vivons
excusez-moi tous les quatre de reprendre
la
parole je voudrais répondre au monsieur
qui a parlé du mariage pour tous pour ne
pas évacuer les
questions parce que c'est des choses
très c'est des choses très profondes et
à mon avis très éclairantes
ou qui devrait être très éclairante sur
notre engagement sur ce que nous faisons
sur ce que nous
sommes mais avant cela je
voudrais remercier les les cinq
intervenants de ce matin signaler
que à mon avis il y a pas beaucoup
d'universités de rentré de partis
politiques qui descendent aussi qui essa
de descendre aussi profondément dans les
questions qu'elle traite c'est-à-dire
d'abandonner l'attitude partisane
purement euh sectaire de on est mieux
que les autres on pense mieux que les
autres pour essayer d'entrer dans euh la
réflexion profonde et à ce titre je
pense que euh cela est notable et cela
nous vaut gratitude à l'égard de ceux
qui se sont très bien très brillamment
et très amicalement
exprimé
alors je voudrais en en quelques phrases
dire dire un mot je ne sais pas où il
est le monsieur qui parlait voilà
euh ce sont des questions
brûlantes euh et brûlante pour un très
grand nombre de citoyens pas pour tous
qui les ont entraîner à s'engager à
manifester pour ou
contre
ce sont des questions qui tiennent à à à
des choix de vie à des à des
sensibilités profonde et peut-être qui
nous font l'essentiel de ce que nous
sommes je connais beaucoup beaucoup de
gens qui ont participé et beaucoup de
gens qui étaient contre ou émus contre
vous pouvez pas imaginer l'importance
que cette question du mariage pour tous
ou de la définition la sexualité a eu
par exemple dans les milieux
musulmans peut pas imaginer à quel point
ça a été important en tout cas dans les
quartiers que je
connais ça a été un un bouleversement
énorme ils ont eu l'impression qu'il y
avait une
imission une imicion de
l'État dans la famille
précisément dans ce que la famille
transmet chose très importante et
sur l'autre rive si l'on peut dire des
gens qui se sont sentis blessés dans
leur sensibilité qu'on leur refuse ça
alors moi je veux pas trancher de la
question d'abord je serais bien en peine
trancher je pense qu'il y a des choses
acquises sur lesqueles on ne reviendra
pas et et que toute affirmation
contraire se heurtera à la réalité et à
l'opinion publique mais je veux dire
simplement une
chose il y a de conception de la
politique il y a les gens qui croient
que la politique c'est fait pour imposer
son opinion aux
autres quel qu'elle soit il y a des gens
beaucoup dans tous les partis
politiques qui pens que l'engagement
politique ça consiste à faire triompher
son idée sur les autres pour que la
société suive votre
idée il y a très longtemps que j'ai mis
ce type
deengagement en
interrogation moi je ne crois pas qu'en
tout cas pour
nous la question soit de faire triompher
son idée sur les autres la question
c'est de trouver un chemin qui
permettent aux gens de vivre ensemble en
respectant des choses absolument
essentielles qui sont notre patrimoine
commun c'est si vous voulez bien de
l'ordre de la laïcité moi je crois que
la laïcité est une choses très très
importantes chose
d'avenir si la France a la dimension de
de rayonnement que Nordine vous vous
évoquiez c'est en particulier à partir
de cela et le fait que qui a été
longuement
évoqué que nous avons un devoir non pas
de tolérance je n'aime pas ce mot j'ai
écrit beaucoup sur lit de tolérance qui
était l de Nant mais mais j'aime pas ce
mot mais un devoir de compréhension
mutuelle qui ne vient pas
seul qui doit être formé qui devait qui
devrait être formé par une éducation
tout au long de la vie dont les médias
en particulier devrait avoir la charge
puisque après tout il y a des cahiers
des charges on donne au médias des
fréquences qui appartiennent à tout le
monde avec des impératifs qui devrai
être des impératifs d'éducation civique
P le le
l'effort qui devrait être fait non
seulement pour comprendre B Saint-
François a complètement raison mais il
sait que je le pense depuis longtemps
l'effort qui devrait être fait pour
comprendre la profondeur des problèmes
qui se posent euh euh droit du citoyen
confisqué par le débat politique actuel
qui a bien compris que le moteur le plus
important c'était la passion et qu'il
fallait faire flamber la passion à à
tout prix et nous nous devrions nous
inscrire en faux contre cette
affirmation l'effort d'éducation et de
compréhension des
autres à laquelle auquel le cinéma
pourrait participer très bien les
chaînes les médias l'école pas trop
parce que j'aime pas queon fasse de
l'école un instrument de
formatage des enfants je trouve que on
se trompe et que là encore c'est un
manquement à la laïcité
mais cette
c'est cette idée qu'on n'est pas là
seulement pour faire triompher ces idées
mais qu'on est là pour essayer que euh
euh ce monde-là puisse vivre ensemble et
pas se fragmenter jusqu'à l'explosion à
mon avis c'est une différence que nous
avons avec bien d'autres merci
beaucoup donc désolé je crois qu'il est
l'heure d'aller déjeuner merci beaucoup
aux intervenants merci à la salle bonne
fin de d'université à bientôt oui s'il
vous plaît juste quelques indications
pour la restauration